could it be more beautiful and appealing
now let's be real the kitchen is tiny so
a small dynamic menu as the seasons
change we go through to spring and some
of them will increase on a daily special
only according to what the business is
about and so we're not buying
unnecessary they were not adding ten
more appetizers and entrees on there
just because we want to look busy
no can be plain and simple keep it plain
delicious and simple let's go through
the dishes a high street burger no water
no water
beautiful pate one of the season I
griddle in there to sit and cook them to
order chicken potpie little modern twist
on a salad nicoise but we've done it
with salmon homemade granola seasonal
berries cheap and easy to put out that
tiny kitchen and then of course the mac
and cheese it does not go in the
microwave with that exactly the sports
bar microwaves has got visually what do
you think it's beautiful and fast and it
takes a big load off in the kitchen yes
we're not buying frozen it's all fresh
right no four four and never a little
taste oh man mmm that is good Oh mom
that's like Mama's macaroni and cheese
people will drive from Washington DC to
come here and eat this way
tonight the towns in relaunches the inn
and the restaurants right how are you
feeling tough week but it's been
instrumental let's put this place back
on the map okay push the freshness of
the menu
I don't anybody panic in there's nothing
we can't do on the menu any issues we
talk about it if we talk to each other
we prevent mistakes happening if we shut
down things will happen without us
knowing Karen I think like this agency
thank you and I'm looking forward to
moving forward good luck
let's go guys
let me hold on the says thank you see it
accounts in checking in it looks like
immediately the guests see the changes
in the dining room and the rooms this is
pretty nice oh you got a nice armoire
and throw our stuff in here how do you
like a change it looks good I can
definitely say this is that's a burger
with french fries BLT and a mac and
cheese
right the kitchen is functioning more
efficiently with a smaller menu and is
preparing the dishes cooked to order and
Karen has overseen the in as an owner
and successfully treating this place
like a business for the first time nice
and crispy the fries the seasoned
beautifully yes yes sir yeah well done
Jeff see me come back yeah what does it
mean a small little local bistro to the
town how good does that feel it's huge
we need more local these doors like this
we're havin Ithaca see it's like a good
night